If if Denims on this platform can't even advertise her only her
only fans, Denims isn't allowed to advertise her only fans on
Twitch, but he's allowed to denigrate her for having an only
fans and remind everyone she's a cuz she has an only fans. I
Yeah, no, that's off. If Denims is allowed to advertise her only
fans, then I think it's fine. You're right, Creaman. He should
be allowed to say this, but she doesn't get to advertise it,
so he doesn't get to harass her about it. I think she should
be grateful for the free promotion, right? She should be thanking
TechTone right now. Thank you, King Techy. Say Say thank you
for the shout-out,
I also have another piece of content. TechTone got banned today,
guys, and he actually went live and talked about it. And I wanted
to check that out. So, let's go.
Banned for That's just terrible. 7 days? 7 days today. That's
just terrible. He called someone else fat? Uh I don't know what
he did here. Hold on. Can we get a Oh, is that not going to pop
up? Hello? Oh, can't can't get it. Never mind. 90 days. Sorry,
we're getting back to this. I was going to go play clip, but
I I literally can't find it, so He said 90 days? He said 90 days.
I started early. Whoops. A little early on the timestamp. Here
we go. Here's where it is. He's going to talk about his not 90
days. Not that. 7 days is how long the ban is. We're a 7-day
ban for for trap that I set for you, Twitch. Yeah. I bet you
didn't know that cuz I was waiting for you to do this. Wait,
32 Oh, no, hold on. losing thousands of [__] man.
Ooh, you guys have a new moon today. This guy thinks he's like
um This guy thinks he's like Yagami Light or you know Lelouch
or something. This guy is totally This guy's a total loser. This
guy thinks he's actually like playing chess out here. What a
What a guy. Who Who thinks of themselves as that guy? And I No,
I can't beat you. Okay, fine. that you would do this. And I knew
the reason would be even stupider than the one before. So, thank
you for once again allowing me to showcase to the world how
stupid you are. Let's go ahead and talk about the hypocrisy,
the double standards, and the preferential treatment of every
single person on this goddamn platform running it behind the
scenes. So, yes, I have been banned once again. Found out about
what? Two
Uh I mean, oh, no. I mean, no.
No. No. Real [__] Oh, no. It just takes It takes
so long to ramp. There's a shorter version of the clip, but I
don't care. I like the long version. Oh, NO.
THAT'S TERRIBLE. OH, YOU HATE to see it. Oh, boo-hoo.
Boo-hoo.
You hate to see that.
Oh, man, you hate to see that. Isn't that terrible? Yeah, that's
a shame. That's a real shame, guys.
We got a nice little Twitter thread going over on the
What don't you understand? watch? Uh this is our reaction to
TECHTONE BEING BANNED. NO. OH.
WE'RE on X. Still not used to it being called X. Uh here we go.
Yep, TechTone been banned already. 2.8 thousand likes. I can't
wait for everybody to call me the worst human being on Earth
and probably compare me to Adolf. I'm going to scroll for two
Oh, the This guy This guy enters the victimhood Olympics. He's
He's like the Michael Phelps, okay? This guy is insane.
He gets banned from Twitter or sorry, Twitch, and he goes, "Yeah,
guys, listen, they're probably going to start comparing me to
seconds. Let's see if I can find anybody saying he's dead. Yeah,
collapse. Nice who dis and they Where Where's the That There
it is. Yep, great. Four times this He definitely He definitely
looked at it, yeah. He definitely looked at it. Dear crazy work,
just perma this guy. an hour ago. Well, just know this part this
loser that you're calling me made uh over $400,000
last month. And honestly, we're on our track to make half a million
this month, so yeah, go ahead and take that [__]
and shove it up your ass. But we are killing it this month. Money
really doesn't buy you Can't buy you class.
Can't buy you class. No. What can I say? 106,000
subs this month on YouTube, brother. That's just insane. Man,
this loser keeps on winning. It is nice. So, uh by the way, Asmongold,
if you're watching this and you said, "That's it. Go [__]
yourself." Okay.
Anyways, anyways, anyways, anyways. So, I yes, have been banned
once again. 7 days, boys. 7 days. Thought it was 2 2 weeks Oh,
don't worry, it's only Oh, we saw the reason there. Hold on.
derogatory quest graphic or derogatory statements or unwanted
content. Or it's only a 7-day ban and no pay for 2 weeks. That's
all right. I already turned off all the ads off of Twitch regardless,
and they can't take my sub revenue, so I will be going live on
Twitch once I'm unbanned again, which I have a prediction.
I predict I will be unbanned in the next 24 hours. Yep, because
I'm about to make y'all look really really bad. And if I'm not,
oh, I got something even better for the follow-up video. So,
if you're new here, make sure to like, comment, subscribe, and
hit the bell for all notifications if you want to be ready for
that. I like to keep bullets in my chamber and only use them
when I have to, but uh you're kind of forcing my hand here by
me over. So, yes, I have been banned for 7 days. Uh of why I
had no [__] idea until I was sent this, which is
obviously
why did I get banned? On streamer VOD, drama gamer reacted new
Stellar Blade. Great game, by the way. Huge drama. Mega content.
What is going on this time? Content creation date, June 23rd,
2025 at 2:26 p.m. UTC. I got to be let know why I got banned
once again, and I was directed to this part of my VOD where you
guys will never guess what I was talking about. Are you like
talking to
God damn it, yes. I'm I'm looking for where he got the timestamp
because this timestamp right here is content creation date. Right?
So, we have a timestamp UTC. So, I don't know I want to know
where he was directed basically. June 23rd, 2025 at 2:26 get
this much info on their bans ever. Well, they said they were
going to add it, and I don't know if they've added it yet. So,
I hope he doesn't think this is a timestamp.
at UTC. I'm guessing he went through and found the actual comments
he made. let know why I got banned once again, and I was directed
to this part of my VOD where you guys will never guess what I
was talking about. You'll never guess. You'll Was it making statements
about Denims again because you were literally told not to do
it in the first place? Were you doing that exact thing you were
told not to do again or Ooh, maybe it was that other girl. What
he say about her booty? Oh, uh minks The minks one? No, I think
that was two or three weeks ago, so yeah, yeah. I also Didn't
he get banned for that? I thought he got banned for that. No,
I think that one skated by and he only got banned for calling
Frogan fat, right? Okay. And we watched and we were like,
that's a crazy thing to say, isn't that for Asmongold?" That
was another crazy thing to say. I do wonder if this one I feel
like it's got to be about Denims. You'll never guess why I got
banned again, guys. Do we have any predictions?
I would love to know.
Who do you think got me banned yet again? Yep. Yourself?
Yourself? Your own words? There it is. That dumb [__]
who's getting her ass soon, and I can't wait for her ass. Did
Denims make him harass her? What was Denims Actually, you know
what? We should go see the VOD. We'll see the timestamp. See
what Denims was wearing, okay? He might have had a He might HAVE
HAD A POINT. HE MIGHT HAVE HAD A POINT, VOODOO. I think I think
that's like actually Iron Mike's defense in Congress as well.
Listen, you didn't see what that was wearing.
Yeah, I had a comment. It's not my fault. has to get perma'd.
Yes, I have been mass reported by Denims community once again
for calling HER A WOW.
AMAZING. AMAZING. And you know what's crazy? I didn't even No,
what's the What's the tweet? He tweeted about this. What is 34
viewers? Moving on up in the world. Must have been doing some
crazy drama. What's up, Crispy? What's up What's up, Chris Raiders?
say Chris plus huge. That's massive stuff, Chris. I mean, realistically,
Chris, I don't know what Chris averages. That's like a big stream.
Everybody starts somewhere. I'm not talking [__]
whatsoever. I feel like No, the more you say it though, the more
I'm like, "Okay, maybe he was talking shit."
It was fine when YOU FIRST STARTED.
DO NOTHING WIN. It is actually She is actually winning. All she
does is laugh at these people, and sometimes she has her cleavage
out, and they actually lose their [__] mind. It's
uh you hate to see it. Well, you don't hate to see it when it
it gets TechTone. You hate to see it. it. I just hate to see
people losing their minds, okay? I want men to win. I don't want
men to be like absolutely like autonomous robots who see a woman
with their out and have to like make comments about it. Autonomous
robots? Yeah, like basically just pre-programmed robots. Like,
"Hey, you cannot comment on her tits. Easy. You can do it. You
have the power." No, as a woman, I love to see this. It is very
hard. The need for me to be right all the time is very difficult.
I do enjoy watching other women get to be wrong. Really, like
always. Just always wrong, terrible political takes, and still
win. I like seeing that for my gender. Uh and we hate to see
it, so obviously. That's what's crazy. That's what's crazy. Is
it crazy? I got banned. He literally got told What did he say
about it? Well, he said he called her a We'll see. He'll I hope
he'll play the clip, but he literally got told stop fixating
on these women and calling them or fat or whatever cuz it's really
weird, and they're they're like upset. like stop. And he literally
just keeps doing it. Because she said SHE WAS UPSET
THAT SHE was being called a And then I said, "If you don't want
to be called that, don't have an OnlyFans." So, I didn't posts
cosplay. What about posting
or posting like cute pictures makes you What's your last girlfriend
Your last living girlfriend a And you also has an argument for
this. If you use It's like if you use your
in the furtherance of financial gain, then you're by definition
a Uh so, do you get to do you get to go on someone's like this
she's not on OnlyFans. She's on Twitch, a platform that he shares
with her. Do you get to bring up
bring that up and
harass her for that? I think even if he did this to her You're You're
allowed to harass women for whatever things that you want, to
be No, no, no. No, on a platform that has like cross-platform
harassment rules and guidelines for Yeah, I I I I think the the
platform is unjust for preventing you from harassing women. Um
I just want to point out that men, either. Teck Tone ended his
uh what? 8-year, 10-year marriage to date a girl from OnlyFans,
to date a girl whose profession was OnlyFans, and to do who did
like nude content as far as I know. So, I don't know where like
he's standing on this as if this is like him talking down. But,
those are the women he likes. So, it's just it's really embarrassing
when you have a preference for something and you will talk other
people for being that thing. Just shows you don't have like a
backbone. You don't know who you are. Kind of
If this guy was like a Christian, he was Oh god. No, I think
it's kind of easy cuz didn't he say he's got like erectile dysfunction
and he can't So, it's really easy to use other people who are
asexual. Uh he I think he's just gay, but yeah, he says he can
only get like dome from
allegations of a as well. I I've been Not allegations. These
are in court documents.
Allegations in court documents? Okay.
But, they are you know, it's a little bit more
Allegations are a matter of public record, yes. Yeah, that's
what we could
Yeah. I don't know I just To me, I sorry, I want to echo the
point, though. I just hate when somebody is like, "Yeah, you're
so hot. I want to [__] you. I'm going to leave my
wife for you. And you're doing OnlyFans. It's so awesome." And
then like once they once they see somebody else who they can
denigrate for, they're like, "Yeah, shut up." Like brother, we
I guarantee you didn't think your girlfriend was a while you
were like trying to date her, while you broke up your marriage
for her, okay? Or you just hate all women, which is I mean, I
guess that's possible. Maybe that's even the most likely. Call
her that. Who knows? I got banned merely for saying, "If you
don't want to be called that, then don't have an OnlyFans." No,
I don't like that. Hold on. If if Denims on this platform can't
even advertise her only her OnlyFans, Denims isn't allowed to
advertise her OnlyFans on Twitch, but he's allowed to denigrate
her for having an OnlyFans and remind everyone she's a cuz she
has an OnlyFans.
I Yeah, no, that's off. If Denims is allowed to advertise her
OnlyFans, then I think it's fine. You're right, Queenman. He
should be allowed to say this, but she doesn't get to advertise
it, so he doesn't get to harass her about it. I think she should
be grateful for the free promotion, frankly. She should be thanking
Teck Tone right now. Thanking Tecky. Say Say, "Thank you for
the shout-out, Tecky." I mean, technically like absolutely Teck
Tone would have the kind of audience That'd be awesome. That'd
be Yeah, exactly. That'd be awesome if if Denims like posted
like new subs like the that boss emails or something. Like just
from like since Teck Tone actually just maybe post a big revenue
bump instead of being a doxing the people who signed up for it.
Probably, but yeah. Yeah, sure. Thanks, Teck Tone, for the shout-out.
She I she would absolutely farm so hard if she just posted like
a If she Honestly, Denims, just fake the bump in revenue, okay?
Sub yourself like 500 times. Say, "Teck Tone, thank you for the
shout-out." Post that [__] to Twitter. Get a million
views and actually make all of your money back, okay? Super easy.
Like clockwork, it'll happen. Be very very simple. Also, somebody
linked me this clip and said it comes from the man himself. jerking
off. That's my That's my ritual. I wake up, I jerk off, and then
I go do my job. But, I woke up Sorry about that. And then I I
covered it up as me scratching my leg. Thankfully, I have a very
small cuz otherwise, I would have been in some Thank god. The
upset confuses jerking off. Huh. He covered scratching his leg
is
I'm so disgusted by men. That was what you heard there? He says
he's a very
Literally literally backing his wife up. Backing his wife's allegations
up, okay?
No, I know. The it's the whole thing, right? It's like smiling
while you talk about your little while you talk about but I can
touch her without getting caught. It could say it just looked
like I scratched my leg. It all of it's like repulsive. Where
Where is Tommy C? Tommy C, tell us he's oversharing. He is oversharing.
This is too much.
I don't know. I don't Insane. know. If Teck Tone's got a grift
like right-wing [__] I think he needs to at least
be honest about the fact that he was like in a show to con bus
he getting blown open. What? I don't even know what those words
together mean. Is it Yeah, basically. it is. That's Okay. even
catch the whole thing. I just heard you say show to con bus he
and I I was checked out for the rest of it. [__]
up. This guy was like in a What is it? There's some Genshin Impact
character that he like liked explicit fan art of. Like it was
some [__] Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. His likes Yeah, when
he he went unliked all of his [__] and he basically
was like, "Guys, I I unliked everything. Don't feel bad."
He like talked He literally posted about it, right? I had to
unlike all my [__] cuz I'm like a professional now.
I'm like an OTK now.
Not smart. wondering, "Wow, Tecky,
well, maybe you shouldn't be saying
You're right. Oh, and by the way, this I'm taking you on a journey
here, right? There's levels to this [__] and I need
you guys to understand how how this is about to get. So, here
we go, guys. So, he had to cry again. The woman, in case you
missed last time I got banned, which is about 2 weeks ago. Wow,
story time with Tecky. There's this girl called Denims who keeps
on calling me a predator, a abuser,
a guy who beats women, and she's called me a
Her buddy, Hasan, has called me a familial obligator. That's
funny. No. You cried about that. You cried about that. You cried.
It's in his like genealogy or something, right?
Like genetically Epigenetic. Epigenetic.
epigenetic memories of and a here photo as you have familial
obligation. Do you think the is actually on the female side,
epigenetic passing things on that they were and they're just
like, "Okay, we're not going to make this as painful for the
next person." Like reduces the size.
possible? I feel like it's possible. Do you think they got banned?
not even a What if he just has like a long [__] He's
Never mind. Just keep playing. I'll keep playing. No. So, he
doesn't Teck Tone actually No, we're on something here. Teck
Tone has heavy FTM
Teck Tone absolutely I could totally see Teck Tone making fun
He kind of looks like the dude from
No, he kind of looks Yeah, he does. He does sound like he's sorry.
I feel like he kind of looks like the uh the FTM dude from Jubilee,
right? Remember the guy who sat down with attitude?
No, that guy looked more masculine.
That guy would never get a Berserk tattoo. That is the gayest
Nothing. They got zero punishment.
I explained to them why they're being called that. I get banned
for 7 days again. I've even tried to clean up my language
when talking about this. But,
I can't talk about Frogan. I can't talk about Hasan. I can't
talk about Denims.
I can't Was he banned for talking about Hasan? What did he say
about Hasan that got him banned? can't talk about any of Yet,
they can run my name through the
for [__] 7
He He didn't get banned for talking about Hasan, but he talked
about Hasan and then
Hasan made him learn about his father being a or something. Apparently,
he acted like he did not know about this. What are you talking?
My dad did what? What? God. Un- unfortunate.
Now, I don't I
In a just world, okay, this guy and Plazuka's switch audiences,
all right? In a just world.
a little bit of tin foil hat here. A little bit of tin foil hat.
I believe
that there might be some preferential treatment going on for
Hasan, Denims, and Frogan. I might believe that anybody
Where did he get in trouble? I NEED TO KNOW. He must have somewhere
where he thinks he got in trouble for talking about Hasan, right?
Where did that happen? Cuz otherwise, he's just blatantly lying
here, and I feel like I don't know why I pause and pretend that
that's absurd anymore. body pushing extreme leftist agenda, these
extreme libtards on the internet. I think someone on Twitch agrees
with them. But then,
that was my thoughts a couple of weeks ago. I thought, "Wow,
maybe they're just not aware."
You know, honestly, honestly, maybe Twitch just wasn't aware
of what they're doing. I I I I I gave them Dude, I gave them
such the biggest benefit of the doubt. I thought, "You know what?
Twitch, do you I called her a but did you not know she's a She
has an OnlyFans. Maybe they just didn't know. God.
Like when I said I only watch when my pants off, that's like
a compliment. I'm literally paying for her content.
what what are you What are you doing? Why did you ban me for
complimenting
That's like a 10 out of 10. Would recommend her OnlyFans to anybody.
If you're black If you're backed up, okay? Denims and strawberry,
that'll do it for you. Backed up. Backed up. Denims Denims is
thick and he just assumed all the black guys are going to want
to watch that. We know where you're going. There's There's lot
of people on this platform. There's a lot of big streamers. There's
Asmongold, there's FaZe Lacey, there's Kai Cenat. There used
to be Ice Poseidon, but they banned his ass, too, cuz they're
You can go watch Mizkif.
Speed shouldn't have got a permaban, but Speed should have gotten
banned for the [__] he said. Speed kinda went off,
okay? some awesome [__] Dude, the one where he just
tells that girl that he's a He's just like
No, no, no, not that one. There's that one on Valorant where
he's saying he's a defender. He's like,
I'm a defender." She said this guy on Valorant. Stop being a
dick. You can go watch Mizkif, the Botez sisters. What are they
doing this time? Mizkif's journey to LA, Barry Pog. You can watch
Sfan play um He's playing variety games. And what was he playing
today? Uh he was playing like uh What Sfan? Death Stranding number
two. You can go watch Seer quirk out. Uh you can go watch Sodapoppin
and Veibae having a huge fight. That is actually a good question.
Every person he listed before that is a total piece of [__]
What the [__] did Sfan do to get included in that
list? I don't know. For a relationship. Just kidding. Uh you
can watch And many of these viewers, maybe they just don't know.
And I genuinely believe that. I thought there's no way there's
actually a leftist agenda.
No way. Why did some Why did a sub in his chat say goon Clancy?
The comment just scrolled up. Dan Clancy really is a gooner,
okay?
Yeah, I'm sorry Dan Clancy's gooning parentheses. not defending.
I'm not I'm not defending, but I feel like uh we only know that
because of you know We We only know that because of Dan Clancy.
Dan Clancy going on like multiple tech shows and being like,
"Look at Twitch's new streamer like reels, okay?" And he just
shows a bunch content. Dan Clancy is a That's who he is, okay?
And God bless him. But I don't think these women get These women
got preferential treatment before Dan Clancy joined the company.
They'll get preferential treatment after Dan Clancy joined the
company, okay? People will do favors for hot girls. That is just
always been true. Stop complaining about it. Stop pretending
one guy doing it, okay? It's like all of men collectively. Shut
the [__] up. Don't blame Dan Clancy for that. That
[__] was there way before he got there. It'll be
there way after he leaves. Sorry, go ahead. No, I'm just recalling
this stream where like uh
a different Dan uh was on like some
some podcast with a bunch of like the streamers and literally
just had them sit there and listen to him yap about Dan Clancy
and Twitch and the anti-Semitism. Yeah, Dan also told them to
go on his stream as much as they want because that's the only
way to get on his stream. Yeah, cuz now look at this guy. And
his chat is like
the hell's that? I know where chat's calling him goon Clancy.
These people are actually like two brain cells. Programmed, yeah.
Yep. So, I set up a little trap. I did. In case you guys are
wondering, last time I got banned
I made sure to inform you guys
that I sent them a folder. And I made And I want to let you guys
know that folder was seen. I wanted to let you guys know that
something big Bro, he's so pressed that Hasan called his dad
a He's so pressed that Hasan like broke this to the world and
he cried about it. He He actually cried to Twitch, too. He didn't
just cry on stream. He literally took those tears, put them in
a little nice little neat folder for himself and sent them on
to Twitch. God damn. was going to happen. Giving them incredibly
good faith. And I want to let you know
nothing happened. Wait, hold on. Cuz we all remembering what
his dad did and we remember he is a a victim of himself. But
like there's a third thing where he tells everybody that his
dad put like a gun to his head and told him, "Give me a reason
not to kill you." Yep. Do you remember that story?
I can't forget that story. That's burned into my head more vividly
than it is apparently burned into Teccy Tone's cuz he decided
to reconnect with his dad after that. Yeah. No, I remember Wait,
what is your point? That his dad's a piece of [__]
Yeah, obviously.
Yes. And that he is probably like a lot of uh trauma from his
childhood from his dad doing that. Yeah. Uh and so his hatred
for like all of these other people who are pointing out that
your dad's kind of a piece of [__] they're all probably
right.
Um they're all right, yes. And I don't I don't understand where
the impetus comes to defend his dad over this, but it's interesting.
I can say that. Nothing. Zero things happened. Now, why do you
think that's a really big issue? Well, let me tell you why that
is. Inside of this folder that I made with the help of my mods,
I had a plethora
of videos and screenshots
that went on for quite a bit, ranging from everybody from Mike
There's no way. Wait, his Get the [__] out of here.
argument His argument for this is MIKE FROM PA CALLED FOR DESTINY
TO GET SHOT. It's Or sorry, maybe to hit him. IT'S ON SIGHT.
LISTEN, you should ban this guy. I know I called Denims a But
if you consider that Mike from PA did this, guys, come on. idiot.
He actually did something to get banned and he's like, "They're
Her community spam reported me. They're trying to get me banned."
But here's a folder of [__] that I tried to get them
banned on. Uh here's my backlog that other people gave me clips
of so I can be a gay op and get these people banned. That's insane.
You know what somebody should do? Somebody should get the clips
of every time Teccy Tone took his wife dad around female streamers
that he either lived with or was rooming and boarding. I think
Teccy Tone really put Emiru at risk of at least seven times.
He put Kuku at risk of like four times, okay? I think he should
get at least a week-long ban for each of the times he he exposed
any OTK-adjacent female streamer to from his father, okay? Without
informing them of the dangers. That's just That's obvious, okay?
Can we get a clip compilation going, guys? Like someone in chat
said uh Hasan saved Teccy Tone like by saying that. So, Teccy
Tone should thank him. Like, no, no. If anything, Hasan helped
save all the other people that Teccy Tone was like normal normalizing
his creepy dad to. Thank God. Hasan saved Emiru, guys. That's
If you ever needed a reason to be a Hasan fan, just know that
Hasan saved Emiru, okay? From the most disgusting of fates. That
went on for quite a bit. She was the one that Teccy Tone said
his dad had a big crush on, right? While he was like living with
her. Yes. Well, not living with her. Um They lived close together.
a couple houses down, Well, they did the podcast. Yeah, cuz Emiru
lived with Mizkif. Yeah, so it'd be two houses down. Wait, but
I hate Emiru, too?
Uh well, then you might hate Hasan. Ranging from everybody from
Mike If you're If you're willing to say that you hate Hasan because
he stopped Emiru from getting That is That is on you, okay? I
don't put that juju anywhere else in the universe. That's some
weird [__] to say. from PA, Hasan, Denims, Frogan,
uh Casey Tron Minx, just to name a few with wonderful little
clips like this. The reason Teccy Tone can't sue me is because
he did that [__] Clips where Denims is saying that
I'm a and I can't sue her uh because well, she believes that
I did it. You didn't include the part where she called you a
and I'm pretty sure the chat that she pulled up and she responded
to also didn't call him a He's just
inserting
the thing that would be offensive and make this egregious and
it just isn't there. Yeah, what is she She's just saying I believe
the allegations against him, right? He did that Yeah, if somebody
was just complaining about her uh believing the the stuff in
the in those allegations from Freeman Pink. Yeah. Yeah. Hasan
is calling Asmongold a
Clips where Denims is calling me a
an abuser, going in on Nux Taku, going
Wait, did Denims call him a too? Denims is more informed than
I would have expected. Damn. on Mutahar, going in on all these
streamers. All of these streamers going in on all
of these uh you know, content creators with complete blasphemous
language. I think this is based. I think you should defend Mutahar
more. I call these people fat. I call a girl with an OnlyFans
a and I get banned now for a total of a
None of them have been banned. So, maybe they didn't see my message
and maybe they didn't do anything with I think if Teccy Tone
isn't a he would post his whole folder, right? Can we get the
Can we get the folder?
I need the folder. So, here's messages with official Twitch staff.
Uh obviously, I've blurred them out. These are messages with
official Twitch staff. This is them. I gave you a nice little
title here. I completely get it. Trust me, you should report
her and send me whatever clips. And by the way, this is me working
with the one good mod uh that Twitch actually has. Or send me
whatever clips or tweets you feel are violative and I can report
them myself and bring them up to the powers that be. It's the
same situation as the Frogan thing and you know it is. You know
how many people were talking about Minx 72 hours ago? The mod
that he says knows what he's doing. The mod that he says cares
and is like actually a good mod is like, "Bro, it's the same
as the Frogan situation. You know you can't just be calling these
women
Like the mod is literally like, 'Dude, just stop actually like
losing your mind and calling these women and you'll be like fine.
Just control yourself a little bit. Have like the smallest modicum
of self-control and you're fine.'" Zero. Yes, 100%.
But bro, her tweet had a million views out of nowhere. It's hard
to ignore something that big after she went after me and my family.
Same thing with Denims. And you reported them both on Twitch
with the links and stuff because it is according to our guidelines
that we will perform action on or off platform behavior, which
means Twitch will I'm sorry, but he went after his dad more than
anyone else. The story of his dad putting a gun to his head is
like the worst thing that I've heard. Oh, you think you think
that's like worse than didn't know that. Yeah, the the harassment
and like no offense to the women in the military.
Uh, it's not that their things are like light or nothing to me,
but the idea that your kid you would put a gun to their head
and make it so that they have to justify why they should stay
stay alive or you're going to take their life. I'm sorry. That
is That is evil. Do you remember why Mike did it? Why Tecktony's
dad did it? Do you remember? I don't remember why. it so much
better. Uh, he left a an empty soda can on top of the trash can.
You think
And realistically his own family. Get the out of here. And realistically
all I'm going to say is realistically that clearly had no effect
on him. He is some kind of like psychopath because how the is
he still a grown He's a grown adult now and he still doesn't
know how to clean the up. So much so that his girlfriend has
to go and talk about how disgusting their house is and he has
to talk about how disgusting their house is. Okay? If somebody
if my one of my parents held a gun to my head because I wasn't
cleaning up and told me to justify why they shouldn't kill me,
me you know, I'd probably be a little bit more tidy in my old
age. All right? Do you think it might be the opposite? if he's
not just totally lying cuz he lied about like the whole you know,
staying in separate rooms. That seems like the most likely scenario
to me, but yeah. Yeah. He probably just totally smeared his dad
with a complete story about him having a gun held to his Just
to yeah, make himself a victim. He's always He's willing to say
anything to make himself the biggest victim in any scenario.
Oh my god, if he is lying can he get his dad to just go on stream
and own up to it? Like dad dad play into this. Play It's a big
epic online meme. Tell them he put a gun to my head as a kid.
That has to be a line that people draw. Right? Oh, wait. Oh.
Uh, it could be. Sorry. So He's reliving trauma every time he
cleans. Yeah, I was thinking that even Morty. Every time he picks
up a can he has to put it back down cuz he just thinks about
when the gun was at his head. Listen, I can't eat your or you
because I was as a kid. I can't clean because my dad tried to
me. I can't do anything. Listen, that's trauma. It's childhood
trauma. Stop asking me to be anything close to a man. Stop. But
in fact, if they thought it was bad
whether the action was committed Ethan is adding Shawn to black
to the
Okay. All right. Um way that you can beat the misogyny charges.
Add racist to it. I'm just I'm just kidding. That doesn't automatically
make you racist by all. Mm. Off the platform or on the platform,
you would get banned if Twitch thought it was bad. Actually,
if it violated their terms of service, right? I think like misogyny
is a I don't think is like a what do you call it? Um
Yeah, class. Like a protected class. Gender is a protected class.
And well, hold on, but would is like a gendered insult. So I
could see them they they have a chance at that one. Yeah. They
have been sent tweets. They have been sent clips. They have been
sent videos. They have been sent screenshots. Everything has
been sent and received via off-screen
violation or on-platform Oh, yeah. Horse harassment. Oh, yeah.
There you go. violations and on-platform violations. They have
all received them based on their own words. According to our
guidelines, WE WILL ACTION on or off-platform behavior if it's
egregious
Labeling people saying they believe the allegations against you.
Not against the
Um, the thing maybe that could be against TOS, but I don't know.
For Tecktony, unfortunately, there is another basis there to
call him a Do I believe he's a because he likes watching little
boys get in terms of like drawn cartoon images? No. I don't I'm
not going to call him I don't know. But I do think it's weird.
be a
might be a weird for a Twitch to ban that and be protective of
people getting when they've literally literally like gone through
the wringer for
some weird activity that's gone on their platform. Do you remember
that? Yeah. They might be gun-shy. BX I think BX Bullet was part
of like expressing some Well, she also reported
What does that have to do with what I'm talking about? She reported
Bax for interviewing Abandem. And she was the one who did
I believe she was the one who did that. No, I was referring to
the the ring [__] or whatever.
That she was saying was happening on Twitch. And I think Abba
and they pulled up her report and read it. Yeah. So I think you
would like these things already exist. It's probably really weird
for you as Twitch to become
uh, protective over people being outed as possibly being uh like
weird degenerates in like an illegal way. Yeah. I they Yeah,
they could just be gun-shy protecting people over that, but it
would be I think like I'm trying to think of why they I don't
know what there would be there that um like I don't know what
guideline that interferes with. Again, it's like based on their
guidelines. We'd have to see what their guidelines
Abusers going after Asmongold's dead
mother. He's just screaming about people being mean instead of
reciting the rules that they're violating.
Probably if you just want to go tie each of those. Like obviously,
I'm guessing the physical violence ones any threats of physical
violence would probably be the easiest ones to get people reported
for. Unfortunately, again just being like Asmongold probably
killed his mom because he she let her keep smoking or something
[__] which is an insane disgusting thing to say in
my opinion. Um
I don't think being mean like that is actually against the rules.
I compile the folder. I submit an appeal. I made all of this.
Appeal sent. Here's the info on Hasan and friends or should I
send it elsewhere? This is great. I can try to pass to the powers
that be. Uh, can we just copy that URL? Oh, let me go find an
OCR thing really quickly. Send it elsewhere. This is great. I
can try to pass to the powers that be. And he did. An official
Twitch staff member took this folder. This was also reported
them by 40 50 members
on Twitch probably from my chat because obviously when my chat
sees someone breaking the TOS, they're going to report them.
They've been reported by my chat. They've been reported by their
own mods. Sent and received with
that it was sent to official Twitch moderators and staff. Nothing
was done. With this, we have 100%
Uh, I was going to say Anyone has a link I'll take it. Can anyone
imagine if Hasan just got on stream and started banning to like
wanted to get people banned? Like deliberately trying to get
people banned for saying bad things about him. If Tecktony is
just here saying Yeah, they they called me a I'm trying to get
them banned. My chat's reporting them. Nothing's happening. For
saying that he's a terrorist No, cuz he Yeah, I think he's saying
bad things about me. Yep. Like Dan Clancy acts a video of him
and staff singing happy birthday to Hasan and people are like,
"See, he's loved so he like uses
uh, relationship with these people to get us banned and it's
all just um favoritism blah blah blah blah. But yeah, if he ever
did even like an ounce of what Tecktony is doing here, it would
just like solidify everything that they already believe with
like not even half of this. The weird thing is is
it would be
Some people have been like What have they been doing? The the
whole like brothel thing. People amplify that all the time. Should
that be like a ban automatically for anybody because they're
like lying about Hasan?
Anybody who said the brothel thing should just be banned from
Twitch, I guess. Like it's just such a weird line that like again
these people talking [__] and then they want to report
it to the authorities. Hey, Tecktony's been talking [__]
He doesn't like that he's facing some consequences and the other
people are within the guidelines. So now he's like trying to
actually report them to the authorities. I wonder if we've seen
this pattern before. My [__] talk my bullying isn't
working. Okay? That Twitch is okay calling the police. with terror
sympathizers. They are okay with people breaking the law. They
are okay with people labeling people as criminals, attempting
to defame them, harass them, ruin their life with false allegations,
as well as go after people's dead parents. And they are okay
with all of it as long as you are pushing a leftist extremist
agenda. You know, starting to think some of those supremacist
people just have a point. Okay? You can just go up to like a
random [__] like this and tell him, "Actually, you
should just lie about Hasan cuz progressives don't have any consequences
anywhere on the internet." You can just say that and he just
like like the golem that he is just starts repeating those talking
points with zero critical thought. Maybe those supremacist people
actually have a point. Okay?
Maybe they do. This is embarrassing.
This is embarrassing on so many levels.
Why why can't this guy just have a critical thought for himself?
I have once again been banned. And by the way, guys, I've shown
you proof of everything and maybe I'll do that one more time
right now. Oh, that'd be cool. Uh, I do believe by the way, yes,
the the them not like banning people, them not doing anything
over the threats, that was stupid, right? I understand those
threats were against Destiny, but not banning not banning those
people for those threats was stupid on Twitch's
Um, and obviously against their TOS. Can we also bring up how
he Did he just get banned today? That's what happened?
For something that he said in a stream like 3 days ago? On the
He said 23rd. 22nd or 23rd, yeah. Yeah, I think so. Yep. So why
the timestamp in the video to start if you want to just see the
screen capture of it in 41:16?
Why are all of these links for this recovery library? Why are
all these links from 20 days ago? Oh, sorry. This No, no, no.
It was in response. It is in response to like his first ban for
calling Denims a [__] I think. Not in response to
this ban.
He's saying nothing was done because if you go back to like the
discussion with the mod, it's like back a little further and
it's uh That's not it. Where's the [__] Discord chat
with the mod? Right here? No. Yeah, the Discord chat would be
for what happened what happened this time.
You would imagine that those links that he grabbed whatever wouldn't
that be in response to how she banned him the last time? I think
this is in response to the ban from last time. So, it's like
I think this is the This is possibly the Minks and Denims comment.
We got something 2 hours
Oh, the 6th June 6th. I'm not June um June 5th. June 5th, yeah.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, and then he sends it the next day, June 6th.
So, the links would be from yeah, 20 days ago, ish. Uh Nikacado
just told me she shamus update on Tectone. Nope, I didn't see
it yet. Okay, I was confused. I thought he was making this library
to send to them after this one, but he's already sent in sent
this to them previously and he's just upset that even after he
sent all of this information about them, he's the one who gets
banned again. Yep. Yeah, that's what he's pissed about. That
he's the one who gets banned even though he showed them proof
that these people were talking [__] off platform,
That that Twitch decided it wasn't that big a deal when they
did it. Got you. But he only showed one clip. He's only showed
Wait, he's only showed one clip so far? I think he said he's
He might be about to go through this period for something.
All right. All right. I I think. I type Uh we'll see if out the
link and gave it to you. You can open it. Oh, wait. Can you You
can open it? Yeah. I just I typed it to you. Oh, sick. I'll show
you the screenshot. Uh awesome. Recovery library. Sorry, I went
and I put it into like a online thing and I didn't I didn't type
it. I knew that you'd have to do that. I I just screenshot it
and typed it, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah. So, we could
go through all of these and see which ones like actually violate.
Also, if you're ever going to do this, if you're going to send
Twitch proof, why would you not basically send them like a text
document that has links and says like here's the here's what
this is violating. Here's what this is violating. Why name it
recovery library? I don't know. He's a [__] loser.
So, June 5th, this is in response to his June 5th ban. Yeah.
Okay. Okay.
These have to be TOS, right? I would imagine they have to be
TOS. Oh, no. What will anyone do if this bald if the bald pervert
leaves the Twitch platform for good? He key Wow. He searched
He key searched bald. BALD? HE KEY SEARCHED BALD. HE DID KEY
SEARCH BALD. He's like, "No, no, no. I am bald, but these people
they call me bald." What? Why? Oh, maybe it's the fat thing?
Like, "Oh, if I can get banned for calling Frogan fat." I guess,
right? If you're going to insult my appearance and I insult Frogan.
Maybe that's where he's coming from, okay? He doesn't like it.
He doesn't like it that he gets called bald. Don't make my me
call my dad. Male humor be like "Uh that is a funny response
and that is an accurate response. Yeah, I just I I'm sorry. You're
bald." he include a Denims W?
Honestly, if this Yara VT person is on Twitch, Tectone should
have been banned for this. He's literally implying he's going
to call his dad to assault them. Like that is That is the actual
implication. So, you can say it's a joke. It is kind of a joke,
but you can't be mad if we're going to take it
You have to take it literally on both
How much of that 400k that he made is like from Denims cuz I
feel like he's just making her look so good like over and over
and over again? He's paying him off. Judge me by my enemies.
Yes, I got
Why is this included? Why is this included? Look Twitch, she
She quote tweeted me. That's harassment.
Maybe Maybe this does go with like a document or something. Maybe
I'm just missing a document here cuz like this makes no [__]
sense to be included. Do Oh, this is included. Do nothing win?
Oh, a Denims is hitting us with a classic again. She I didn't
know Denims was following up on a on old tweet, okay? It's the
same one. Do nothing win? Do nothing win? I sent them a scattered
folder of images and videos with no context and they banned nobody.
There's no way that's what really happened, right? He also cried
on stream that he was
a victim and had a gun point to his head, so.
He did do this. Kick recruiting a fascist during pride month
is so brave. This is just accurate. This is literally after you
talked about jerking off to her on stream. Why is she attacking
the
I I think it's hilarious for her to be like a leftist progressive
and make that joke. I think she's funny.
Dude, uh this is What is this included for? Parading your dad
around like he's an honorable man, but when he's exposed his
Tectone responds by saying he has cancer irrelevant to being
a was only 17 years ago when he was a young man, 50-plus years
old. It's all alleged. Served prison time. I again
do not understand. This was his trap, guys. This is This is his
meticulously crafted trap to show that Twitch is broken, okay?
Their system is broken. I sent them all of these tweets of Denims
owning me and they didn't even ban her. What the [__]
What the What the [__] I will also point out that
I do not believe Tectone was banned for calling Frogan fat the
first time or the third time or the fourth time, okay? I believe
it was like after a week or 2 weeks of just calling her fat every
day. Yeah. Then they're like, "Hey, okay. You got to stop." comment.
Well, it's uh I'll zoom through these. What I don't even know.
This is just a random chat log? They kek L. They kek L at him.
That's harassment. I don't even the Oh, hold on. Yeah, current
path recovery library. Is this it? There's no like We go back
to There's no thing before this. I There must be a document explaining
that we don't have. Cuz if there isn't, then none of this makes
any sense. Uh this is a Jake Chinatown thing. The logs of Is
this screenshot showing Hasan showing the Jake Chinatown tweet
about Tectone crying? He just said he sent a folder, right? Uh
I guess. Maybe it's the same thing. crimes in the congressional
record, man. Why are you still chirping? I That's it. He didn't
know that his dad was convicted. He just found out.
Ignore the fact that his ex-girlfriend
said that his dad said that those women were lying to her. Uh
he just found out. Yeah, yeah, yeah. The ex-girlfriend did point
out that he had brought it up or it was some topic of conversation
from before. I like this one where it's like trying to basically
say It's trying to say like, "Look, she says this is bad, but
also look over
So, Denims talks about you. Dude, I only watch Denims clips offline
with my pants off. I can't watch those on stream. Amidst abuse
allegations, Tectone harasses another streamer. And she quote
tweets that and says, "Interesting move to harass a streamer
after trying to disprove your abuse allegations, but we can see
what @Twitch @TwitchSupport think." And then the response to
this is she has an OnlyFans and a Fansly. This is like This is
like This is comically bad. This is like um Oh, I can't even
I can't think of a good comparison to this. This is like embarrassing
that he was bragging about how he caught Twitch. He got them,
guys. They fell for his trap card. Makes me think he needs a
caretaker. I Dude, uh-oh. This might be not a good one. Asmongold
talking about Hasan again. Hasan is retweeting people calling
me mom murdering He's calling Tectone a generational familial
obligation to Where's the lie, though?
Said Palestinians are an inferior culture that deserves genocide.
Promotes the AfD.
Wanted to dress up like Ash Ketchum and stream a deportation
ride-along with ICE. Demands I get banned. Defends Tectone. But
I'm the villain cuz I retweet someone who's mean to him on a
separate tweet. I'm sorry, but didn't Asmongold already lose
to Hasan? Asmongold literally stopped streaming and cleaned his
house. He lost. Yeah? Right? Yeah? Yeah? Basically, yeah. Like
he self-flagellated right there. He did. "All right, you guys.
I'm I'm going to clean my house. I never do this. I'm going to
clean and I'll give you guys photos." Yep. Yeah. But Asmongold
was banned Yeah, Hasan got preferential treatment. Absolutely,
Hasan got preferential treatment. I hope that's over now, but
he did get preferential treatment before. Why did you assume
this was about you, buddy? Oh, hold on. Hold on. So, I'm genuinely
considering full swapping to YouTube if this terrorist propaganda
isn't punished harshly and immediately on Twitch. My father,
my brothers, and our soldiers did not bleed
There's uh his father's a shield, by the way. My father, my brothers,
and our soldiers did not bleed, sacrifice, and die for this to
be ALLOWED AND PROMOTED on Twitch. This needs to be changed immediately.
Why did Oh, sorry. Oh, no. What will anyone do if the bald pervert
leaves the Twitch platform for good? He responds, "Why did you
assume this was about you, buddy? Is this because you're you
know you're pushing terrorist propaganda, which is directly against
TOS? Kind of weird, big guy." Uh no, you you like hang out with
people who rail on him for the same thing. No, he It's I mean,
it obviously most likely is about him, but Hasan's literally
just like laughing at somebody threatening to leave. It's like,
"Hey, your presence is like are they wanted? Like, 'Oh, no. What
will we do without another' terrorist propaganda thing. He's
just like Tectone sucks. Who cares if he Who cares if he leaves?
That's a good point, yeah. Yeah, yeah. It's like when um It's
like when the the hot tub streamers complained, "Oh my god. They
banned me. All I did was wear a thong." Like, "Okay. Oh, how
How terrible. Oh, no. What are you going to stop streaming on
Twitch and only stay live on your OnlyFans? Oh, no. Twitch is
really losing out." Oh, no.
Tectone literally had a video he made about Hasan under that
tweet. I Okay. Oh, so basically under this tweet there was a
video about Hasan.
So, it's directly about him. And then he's like, "You think this
is about you?"
God, this guy is a This This guy is special needs. And honestly,
there's a decent chance if you saw these two walk past you in
the in the mall, you might think this is like her
Right? That she's taking care of, like her actual caretaker.
Oh my god, he put the beanie over the glasses like that. Yet
another Oh, whoops. We are not on good terms. Fream opens up
about her ex-husband Techtone says, "Some things shouldn't be
used for content." Yet another male victim of divorce court.
Send your thoughts and prayers everyone so that he may recover
one day. This is not against any TOS.
Why is this included in anything?
What is happening that this would be This is his By the way,
this again, to remind you guys, this is his folder of like screenshot
evidence that Twitch is super biased in not banning these people
for off-platform behavior. Right? He's shown them the evidence,
all the evidence they need to ban all these streamers for off-platform
behavior. He has not proven out his case once except maybe with
somebody who called him bald. But realistically again, uh it
was a repeated thing with Frogan, the fat thing. So, I don't
know. Sorry, why Why is he crying? Nobody should doubt that saying
women followed in his footsteps and is trying to blame it on
Hasan. LMFAO, okay. This is Minx saying she believes, I guess,
the allegations because Jstarky so He thinks he's being banned
for being mean, not for TOS.
Yeah, I don't I don't
Okay, we're almost through the screenshots. We're almost through
it. He's not He literally said his viewers don't care about this
His viewers will never stop supporting him. He could do whatever,
they don't care. They're there for the video games. They kind
of are. He knows he's They're there for those games. Uh this
one I remember this one. This one kind of was gross to me that
Casey tried to talk about her his like dead mom to try to go
after him. That was so stupid, but Is it really November 2024?
Jesus. How's that so long ago? Cry at Asmongold. As your type
always says, "Facts don't care about your feelings." Also, how's
your other allegedly buddy, Techtone Oh, she added the allegedly.
So, he's totally good here. Yeah, no TOS violations possible.
Cool. Smart? Smart?
Okay, this is a 1-minute clip. I need to go get a drink really
quickly. I'm going to play this clip. I'm listening. Okay, I'll
be right back. Okay, Hasan clip. If there is no crime, you cannot
go after someone for simply speech that you don't like. That
statement inherently is contradictory.
You can't just be like, "Well, I've decided you can deport people
who are legal permanent residents because I don't like their
speech." Okay, then you're not for free speech. Then you're not.
You don't like the current existing American free speech protections.
You don't want non-citizens to have free speech protections.
Maybe that's what you're trying to say. Okay? I guess that's
what the the statement is here, which is still ridiculous.
the standard of free speech isn't just like what you've chosen
that you don't like. It's across the board, at least in America.
There are some exceptions to it, but it's like Ma- Ma- Ma- Ma-
Ma- did not violate any of those standards. Okay. I WHAT IS HAPPENING?
THAT'S LIKE THAT'S THAT'S
How Techtone is taking one of the few cases where Hasan's making
a political point that is correct and valid, and he's putting
it in this thing that's proving that people should be getting
banned? I don't understand.
This is like How did you find the one time Hasan was correct
and valid in a political opinion and put this in your complaint
folder?
Couldn't you found any of the trillion times he's been a complete
and utter Are you sure this is Techtone's folder? Yes, it's literally
called recovery library. It's all about Techtone. This point
is actually good. They found a point Hasan was making that is
a Okay. Oh, maybe that is the point. Don't ban me cuz Hasan would
disagree with it. him to mail. But it's it's gross as Okay? That
wasn't the part I was talking about Brokey watching until you
bring up the content nuke to see his reaction. I don't care about
Ethan's reaction. I don't even want to see it anymore. I'm just
so pissed off. What are we doing? What the [__] are
we doing? How How are we so goddamn cruel? You know what I How?
How was that allowed? How do other people in the community don't
check these people? You know what I mean? Why is that Why is
that appropriate? Why is that in any way, shape, or form appropriate?
Like that's a [__] peer, okay? Yeah, I'm sorry she
doesn't have [__] 30
live concurrent viewers. No, I don't have any write access to
this folder. would suck up to her and respect her. Gross. Gross,
dude. I I I actually have no idea. I I kind of want to go back
to his video cuz I hope he's going to take that folder that he
said he was going to look at and look at the folder.
Now Now I'm going to feel bad if he has a document he's going
to pull up. Uh I see his Kick dashboard. I don't see him pull
a folder up. Yeah, I don't think he pulls Let's watch for a second.
We'll see what he says. I I'm going to ask you guys to take my
word for it because I have HONORED MYSELF
OH,
TAKE HIS WORD FOR IT. IT was nice of him to show the folder on
screen, the things he's complaining about. Guys, I'm just going
to ask you to take my word for it, okay? They really did [__]
up. Twitch fell into my trap. They [__] up, and you
just take my word for it, okay? They embarrassed themselves
massively. And I pride myself by always telling you guys the
absolute truth and providing you proof with absolutely everything
that I possibly can. And if it's requested enough, I suppose
I can show you more DMs. However, I'm very angry and I don't
feel like censoring these things out again because my brain hurts
and I'm doing this live, and I just got another DM right before
I made this video that I didn't edit. They sent me a DM on how
to deal with this, and they told me to just ignore them. That's
their solution. They want me to just Guys,
you telling me to just ignore them is you telling me to have
people send me career-ending false allegations, going after my
friends, going after my friends' dead parents, and just ignore
it. What type of disgusting
monsters do you have to be to expect me to be able to be defamed,
slandered, have my livelihood ripped away from me?
Defamation or slander, you can sue. You should sue. Why don't
we sue? Can we sue? Can we just sue? Have them go after people
who I care about so much, more than I care about myself, including
their dead parents, and say, "Well, Oh, he definitely cares about
Asmongold's dead mom. He's not pulling something up from 2024
to try to make a point at all. He definitely cares way more about
Asmongold's dead mom than himself. Actually, now that I think
about it, he totally talked about his like multiple as a kid
when Asmongold's dead mom when Casey tried to make fun of Asmongold's
dead mom, right? It definitely wasn't when Hasan just made a
point to like dunk on him, and then he trauma dumped every single
bad thing that happened in his childhood. I Just ignore them.
That's not how this works.
I would be able to [__] ignore them if you did anything.
I gave you 3 weeks
with a compiled, easy-to-read folder.
UH A COMPILED, easy-to-read folder, guys. WE'VE BEEN I'VE BEEN
WAITING FOR WEEKS. THAT THIS IS THE FOLDER, by the way. We've
been looking at the folder.
This folder's [__] embarrassing. None of these people
ever talked Uh of None of these people never had anyone talk
[__] about them in their lives. I They have. They
They like deal with it. Once you get to a certain size, I don't
know, you just stop like actually engaging with reality. Like
this guy's a big streamer now, so he's like, "Oh, this is defamation
because they talked Yet I get banned in less than 24 hours after
my  infraction.
You're going to have to keep banning me over and over and over
and over again. Because if these people are coming at me, coming
at my friends, coming at their relatives, coming at MY RELATIVES,
COMING AT THEIR DE-
WAIT, DID HE JUST SAY COMING IN MY RELATIVES? Uh Why? You're
going to have to keep banning me over and over and over and over
again. Because if these people are coming at me, coming at my
friends, coming at their relatives, coming at my relatives, coming
at their their deceased relatives, I'm going to have to say something.
is wrong with them? Uh
He said coming in my relatives. That is what he said, yes. Um
Does he have more than just a dad? No, I think his mom was culpable
in some of the bad stuff that happened to him, so I don't know
if he talks to his mom at thing. When they're blasting this out
to millions of people every day, and yes, Twitch, it bothers
me if they're promoting terrorist propaganda.
When I take pride in living in the United States of America,
where many of my friends and relatives were soldiers who I care
about very much. They were united in [__]
Uh
God. Despite everything, I don't care. Despite everything, I
DON'T CARE. By the way, if you don't know, THAT IS HIS ORIGINAL
DAD TWEET, RIGHT? My family, my dad, my brothers, my family bled
for this country. I won't allow terrorist propaganda on Twitch.
That's just his tweet reworded, and then because he knows he's
been blown up for bringing up his dad, he actually says after
that, "I don't care."
States of America
When I take That flag wasn't there behind him like last week.
My friends and relatives were soldiers who I care about very
much. Despite everything, I don't care. Yep. I respect our soldiers.
I love our troops. I don't understand.
Wait, can you catch me up? I got lost. What does he care about
and what does he not care about? He cares about his family members
who were soldiers, like his dad, despite everything, I don't
care. So, he's like, "I don't care about other people getting
mad about my dad. I still care about him because he was a soldier."
Um
You guys army? was a soldier? Cuz he was his dad. Because he
was a soldier and a family
But he's trying to say because he's a soldier, he hates terrorist
propaganda.
That's why he hates Hasan. Maybe he has like a fetish for soldiers.
That's like his thing.
Maybe. Maybe that's why he plays all of these like Japanese games
where you can have the little girls be soldiers. Little girls
and little boys. Yeah. Take their sacrifices for granted. You
all know this is happening. This is undeniable proof you know
this is happening. And yet you still do nothing. It's pathetic.
Undeniable proof this is happening. Wait. Undeniable proof Wait,
what?
I respect our soldiers.
Respect some. I love our troops and I don't take their sacrifices
for granted. You all know this is happening. This is undeniable
proof
You You all know this is happening. Brother, your thread has
like your This This folder has no like discernible thread other
than these people don't like you. It's like here's here's like
me getting owned multiple times. Here's me getting owned dozens
of times. Twitch, DO SOMETHING. TWITCH, STOP THEM. TWITCH, YOU
GOT TO STOP THEM. PLEASE.
LET'S STOP THEM. Stop them. This folder really is a Denims' highlight
reel. I didn't know that she could make like the
the gay pride jokes. I That just That actually humanizes her
even more. Uh I It's about to become a Hasan highlight reel I
think. The next couple clips are all Hasan. You think the URL
in chat? I'm too lazy to type it.
Hold on. Let me um
Let me go to the top level and download. Unable to download.
Too Size is too
Well, somebody should go and download all of this. Hold on. Can
I open this in another thing here? I just don't want to lose
any of this stuff. I don't want to not have it. So, okay. Can
you let me download something else? No, you only let me download
one thing at a time? Just open up all the tabs, right? Well,
you can. Whatever. You can. Um There's like a download button
that wasn't letting me go through some of the other ones here.
Oh. Oh, it's just the Once you click one of the download buttons,
they go away on all the other ones it looks like. Oh, no, they
don't. Oh, what the [__] Oh, I think Okay, I'm clicking
through. Give me 2 seconds to click through all of these. God,
I can't believe I'm doing this manually. Really grinds my gears
to do something like this manually and not just find something
to do it Let's see what smelly jean in chat has to say while
you download. Smelly jean says, "This stream is just all three
of y'all" Oh, excuse me. "Acting like kids in a circle
competing
who can spit up in the sky the further?" What game is that? And
then got the audacity
to look at your parents and tell them
"We were just changing the word." Low-key hoping Ethan win. What
the [__] does this have to do with Ethan? "And set
a precedent" of Who's going to set a precedent of of what? The
United States? With this lawsuit he's going to set a precedent.
So, you are forced to swim or drown. Just love to hate-watch
this community get burned. Um Hm. I'm Those are the people supporting
Ethan and they couldn't be less intimidating. Oh, this guy posted
some other stuff that was funny tonight.
Hold on. Let me Let me read this. I saw this get posted and I
I didn't read it cuz it seemed incomprehensible, but let me see
what kind of stuff I doubt president.
He did.
Well, racism is an old thing. So, is okay is I say it and to
call other black
Calling a woman a Wow, get that woman hater out of Twitch. Him
and his dad are going to every woman. Good pathetic act, my boy.
Uh actually, no, I don't think you could do this on Twitch. I
think if I was a white person I called a black dude on Twitch,
I think I would I think I would get banned. I don't think I could
do that actually. I think that's against TOS. I am his friend
and if he ever called me an I would him. I thought of several
ways that I would do it. Seven to be specific.
This is weird. I don't even know what this guy is saying. This
guy like watches a lot. Trying to see who this is. He said He
said, "Not I'm Dominican like Cherry." No, you're French Canadian
almost certainly. I'm sorry, this is like French Canadian typing.
I'm almost I'm almost positive, bro. Tell me the truth. Are you
French Canadian, Smelly Jean? Be true. Be real right now. What's
a what? What's a babka?
Somebody said who wins Cherry v. Babka. Uh that is
someone who streams with I think. Yeah. I don't think I've heard
of them. They might be in the Discord here. I'm not totally sure.
Oh, other people want the link. Oh, right. I wanted to download
all this stuff before they actually before they actually get
rid of it. There's no way this dude actually be in this dude's
chat to so you you could do that. I did download Yeah, I downloaded
all of them. Okay, you're done? Okay. Yeah, I'm done. All right,
there's no way What? Uh I don't know. I don't even know what
I was saying, but we're we're good. We're good to continue on
with Tectone and see what he has to say. Jesus. proof you know
this is happening. And yet you I'm like dehydrated for this stream
now. I I need more water. YOU STILL DO NOT DRINKING Not drinking
enough water. You still do nothing. It's pathetic. You are pathetic
and the only thing that you're doing
is you're going to make me grow
and get bigger and bigger and bigger because I'm not going to
let you bully me. I'm not
Um when Twitch doesn't ban When Twitch doesn't ban Denims for
making fun of him, okay, with no intrinsic traits at all, that
is Tecto That is Tectone being bullied by Twitch, okay? When
they don't protect Tectone from the big mean brown lady just
laughing at him or saying that he's harassing her, that's actually
Twitch
bullying him. That's crazy. going to let This is This is the
power of like self-victimization, okay? This man can turn himself
into a victim in any situation.
It's totally broken. Do you guys remember that we needed like
the nerf on Hasan and his race swaps? How he would switch races
all the time to whatever he needed to be to be like the victim
in a situation? Tectone is like the omni-victim. He can make
himself the victim in any situation. And he's white. He's a white
male and he will just be like It'll be like, "Tectone,
it seems like you lied here." And he's like, "I was twice before
I was 15." And it's like, Black people are racist. Ask people
in America, Jstark. Yeah, well, if He probably qualifies as trans
if you have a They try They trying to make this guy go in the
women's restroom. You realize that? That's what Trump is trying
to do right now in your more convenient.
They're going to take his testosterone away. All right? He's
already He's already lost the hair. They're going to make him
go bald and then they're going to take the testosterone away.
It's crazy. But you silenced me.
Uh Okay, play play.
I'm not going to let you encourage me to just ignore it AND NOT
TALK ABOUT IT. HOW ABOUT YOU GET your head out of your ass and
you do your jobs. You have a TOS. is so brave. Enforce it. I'm
tired of my friends getting harassed
day by these disgusting human beings
that call themselves streamers when in reality all they do is
pull up CNN
and walk away from their chair. They will be replaced by AI in
the next 6 months. No, they won't.
They are like the demographic that won't get replaced by AI.
People making scripted videos
um
and trying to give like political commentary in scripted formats
are probably what's going to get replaced. I don't even know
what you'll be able to AI generate with scripts and stuff. All
right, Denims. Denims probably could be replaced by AI. Uh no,
Denims can't be replaced by AI. I don't think so. She doesn't
really She doesn't do very much. They like her because it's like
it's watching a VTuber, but you know it's real. They like they
specifically want the real aspect of it. You could go watch a
fake one. They've got the real one. Cherry wasn't misogynist
enough. I didn't think Cherry was misogynist enough to give the
right take there, but that is exactly what I was going to say.
How does this guy doubt me? That is what people are there enough.
I'm racist enough. I'm bigoted enough. I'm ableist enough. Every
time. Okay. You. Yeah, I shouldn't have doubted. Yeah, I shouldn't
have doubted.
Pre-planned clone. Pre-planned clone. If there's a terrorist,
just make the streamer pog. Great. I don't know what the [__]
you
are doing there back at Twitch,
but I suggest you try enforcing your TOS equally. That way you
get some of the credibility you once had back cuz I assure you
you do not have it now. And thank you, Twitch, because I'm sure
once this video gets released and this will be talked about by
everybody. Once again, thank you for giving me 1 million subs
on YouTube. I'm going to go get a golden retriever in celebration.
Twitch, go [__] yourself. May God have mercy on your
soul. Do your job. Unban me. That's the video. Like, comment,
subscribe. See y'all next time. Peace.
I forgot that he does that. That now he has people who write
his scripts and he just has like scripted segments and he just
does scripted segments the whole time. I forgot that he does
that now. It's always so jarring that he does that like through
stream. It's so effective though. Hm. I really need to do better
about this. How long is the ban? 7 days. That's what Papagape
would do. Or maybe still does. I don't watch his streams.
like his live streams, he would be doing takes to cut, snip,
and edit and put on um Tik Tok. Oh. That's smart. He never He
never made his Tik Toks like off stream or anything. People just
be there while he's like running his takes to do it. Yeah? No,
I think that's smart, to be honest. I think it's smart to find
a way that's less Maybe this is smart though. I don't know why
you need to do that.
Maybe it feels more authentic. Why you wouldn't just have like
a like a ending reel or whatever, but maybe it just feels more
authentic. I'm not totally sure. Uh What are you going to name
Oh, right right right. Uh we don't care anymore. Uh I'm going
to name it Mango, but that weird ass guy from C9 made the name
Mango weird. Which sucks. All right, let me tell I would trust
my if I had like a sister or something, like a 20-year-old sister,
I would trust my sister with Mango way more than Tectone. But
there's no way that he's complaining, "This guy was like creepy
and pushy and now the word Mango is weird." Any self-awareness?
No self-awareness. Maybe if Maybe if Mango went to rehab, okay?
I wouldn't want my sister to be with the drunk. That's just That's
But that's more of a drunk thing, not assault thing. I think
she'd be more likely to She'd be more likely to run into those
problems with Tectone. But with Mango, I it's just a drunk in
general, okay? But he IS ALSO THE GOAT. HE IS ALSO THE BEST FALCO
OF ALL TIME.
SO, I mean
you know It's just goofy to imply like he's even worried about
how he's going to look. I Yeah, he he has zero thought about
it. It's like over. I I don't He already posted I don't think
this guy cares about looking or
Uh, no, like outside of this. I I don't think that's like part
of his persona. "Oh no, I'm so worried. I don't want anybody
I want everybody to think I'm a good guy. Now it can't be named
Mango cuz that's going to make me look weird cuz the weird stuff
that that guy did. I would never do those weird things. Anyway,
now let's go play this like Gacha game. Okay, they're not
They're not They are Okay. They're not Japanese people. Okay,
oh, no, hold on. Japanese people are super but not in the context
of I think it's always weird if it's No, because what you don't
understand is they are Don't say no to
They can't consent, does he No, they are It's only like uh it's
only in terms of the body types, okay? In terms of the mind,
they are thousand-year-old spirits. But if it is
the magic children they can consent, Jerry, okay? That's No,
they That's basically That's He gets it. This guy gets it. Go
figure. Whatever. What a thought. You know what? They were trying
to find the one area where I'm not edgy enough and they found
They actually they actually got you games. It's just like, you
know, there's like scantily clad 12-year-olds basically. What
can you do? You guys win. All right. It's just so I can't be
wrong. Uh, tell it to Denims and Tectone, okay? Tectone doesn't
even Tectone thought he could never be called His doesn't even
work if it attempts to enter an orifice that isn't a mouth, okay?
He didn't think he was allowed to be called the He thought he
found the loophole.
You can't even get hard if it's going against a vagina any vaginal
wall, okay? He thought he was immune.
He thought he was immune.
But he's not immune. Okay, so I'm not I'm not saying this is
I don't know what Tectone did. But do you think there's actually
a case where a guy argues, "Nope, I didn't her. Judge, let me
just show you my dick." Because he thinks that if it's micro
She Like there's actually like this like So, yeah, this is like
this takes both of us working together to like actually get something
going here. So Well, it's also her mouth, right? Like literally
No, you could literally hurt somebody by just slamming your body
into them over and over. You don't have to Listen, there's zero
trauma to her throat, but her nose has been smashed into pieces
by his fupa, okay? It's [__] up. That's assault.
That's assault. And if you doubt it, it's assault. [__]
you. [__] you. The fact that your dick can't go past
1 in doesn't matter. It's assault. [__] you. It actually
makes it worse, okay? Yes, it He needs to push back that like
fat around his to get any entry into anything, so he's got to
force his He's got to force his hips forward hard, okay?
It makes it worse because people cannot help if they have a micro
okay? And they need empathy. They do not need the motivation
to believe that they could take their anger
out of their birth defect
out on every other woman in the world. It's I I imagining like
a serial micro dick right now. Yeah, like Well, I'm seconding
your I hate this place. That was such a great
Listen, I'm just going to let that settle in on people.
Uh, they get it. The people get it, okay? I don't even know if
Cherry heard me. I think Cherry heard me. No, I don't even know
what you just said what was just said. Oh, I said like Cheerios.
Cereal
micro I don't get it. He Cheerios! Oh.
Thank you. God, I make one funny joke in like years and Cherry
doesn't even hear it. It's so [__] up. It's [__]
up. It's not funny. If you pretend I'm sorry, the joke's not
funny. And now she's laughing saying it's not funny. Why do you
just do the opposite to me? I'm laughing because you I don't
know. I did the thing where I just like pretend I didn't hear
it so we can move on. Like for you. to disconnect. I'm going
to disconnect, okay? Tapping out. That's it. Not funny. Not funny
to joke like this, okay? Okay.
Yeah, okay. Are we going to keep going through some of this?
There is like the pirate software stuff. I don't I don't know
if I want to start it right now. What do we got? We got 5 minutes
left on the stream right now?
I think we have more than 5 minutes. I think I have to be intellectually
honest with the stream and say that we got an hour and 5 minutes.
Cuz I believe Well, I just hit all of the goals for for financing
and that means an eight eight hour 15 to 8 hour 30 minute stream.
And I think we're at 7 hours 30. Yeah, 7 hours 20. We definitely
have another hour on the stream that I just was not I I didn't
count the time correctly. So, I'm going to be honest with you
guys and say I didn't count the time correctly, but we did make
it to 8 hours on the stream, so we do have an hour left. Not
sure exactly where I'm going. I We have the pirate software stuff
or we can keep watching the Tectone clips. The Tectone clips
I just want to know if there's like actually going to be a TOS
violation against Tectone in here. Will we get a single one is
the question. A single actual TOS violation against Tectone that
took place off platform. Tectone clips, okay, okay, hold on.
Next Tectone clip. Oh, I'd opened it and we didn't hit play.
What is this? considering full swapping to YouTube if this terrorist
propaganda isn't punished harshly. Wait. Did Tectone think Did
Tectone unironically think him posting this is not going to be
a call for celebration? Why? How in the world is Uh-huh. Where
Where Where is the TOS violation? Where is What He's He said
this is a folder full of like the most unforgivable like uh violations
of any, you know, of either moral violations like with the Asmongold
bomb comment or actual TOS violations like terrorist support.
What am I supposed to be watching here that's that's wrong or
anything weird? Oh, this will be This might be one. But I got
to be honest with my experience in life with people like Ethan
the only thing that ever knocks them out of their spiraling is
is the rod. It's the Why does he have a react clip of this? stick
I don't know. the carrot. Okay, chief. Like they feel He feels
like he's he's bullying you. He feels like he's hurting you.
He's not going to Oh, I've seen that before, Emime. Like uh Mewtwo
King when they basically uh they accused him Somebody accused
him of assault and he was like, "MY DICK DON'T WORK, BRO. You
lied. You lied. I have documented documentary evidence. My dick
ain't even work, bro. It's It's over for you." stop until he's
you know, he's bleeding out of the corner of his mouth. And I
get it. I want to be empathetic Like I understand the value of
empathy. I understand the value of trying to reach out to someone.
But somebody like Ethan, he needs to get He needs to see some
stars before he's going to back down. You know?
I think he said, "Okay, chief." Mike should sue him and say this
was not transformative. Also, I'm not a chief. So, his his commentary
is inaccurate. I don't know. Jeez.
with that one I get where that's coming from. Personally, I think
that could possibly be Mike speaking metaphorically. I think
you could argue I might even argue that Twitch should probably
play that a little uh tighter. When it comes to things that could
be interpreted as threats of violence, you probably do have to
action as a platform.
I I I think probably Mike's being metaphorical there like as
in you can't back down from Ethan, he's being a bully. You have
to fight back. You can't just like be a [__] I think
that's probably what's happening, but I think you have to action
on it. And Mike has a history of actually making physical threats,
so It's on sight. It's on sight. Deserve 9/11. He was very obviously
saying that someone should hit
I I don't think so because he's speaking in metaphors and he's
talking about like seeing stars. I think he is I think he is
not literally saying that personally, but in any case, even if
he's not literally saying that, I think he should still be It
should be actioned on as if he were saying that. Because it's
difficult to know It's difficult to know and other people can
use that with plausible deniability to not get banned, Dude,
people literally got away with saying yourself in a video game.
Let's not act like the most does not just like slip through.
Why does that work? It's so dumb. People on TikTok get away with
saying Listen, I would never talk about On the other hand though,
on the other
that's horrifying. Deserve 9/11. Very strange. Okay, hold on.
Am- America deserve 9/11. Is this the Osama bin Laden manifesto?
It is the Osama bin Laden manifesto
with no other citations. How is somebody reviewing this supposed
to know what it is? But it says we disavow this on the screen.
Deserve dis- Oh, true. We all disavow this. We are learning.
We all dis- WE ALL DISAVOW THIS. We are learning. I hadn't heard
Denims disavow Wait, but but this is literally why
the policy was brought in was this stuff. So, he's saying he's
using this to say it's a TOS violation. Yeah, they decided it
wasn't a TOS violation, but that wasn't the change that they
were going to retroactively. Sure. Well, it was close. We almost
had the first like TOS violation here against Techtone. No, wait,
not against Techtone. This is just a Dan's TOS
Still not against Techtone. Okay.
Wait, she also get banned for this? She absolutely got banned
for the Bin Laden action action TOS violation that wasn't even
a violation at the time. Awesome thank you Techtone. This is
against Techtone because his father was in the military. Oh,
right.
His father literally served in the Middle East. He like got He
like lost skin on his legs. No, I think in Vietnam, right? No,
the Middle East.
Like Iraq or something. He's not that old. Come on.
Come on. I can't disavow facts, man. I can't disavow reality.
The same way America deserved 9/11. America deserved 9/11, dude.
I'm saying it. Leftist pre Hasan also Did Hasan not also get
banned for America deserves
Yeah. Each and foam at the mouth at the thought of a revolution
happening in America, but as soon as it happens From Stardust's
video on Frogan.
This is definitely taken from some This is definitely taken from
like Listen, I don't have Dan drenched in sweat, but I feel like
this is a Dan video.
I'm almost positive. No, but Dan But you understand Dan doesn't
make his own videos. I don't think there is a single person who
would put that there except for Stardust. Oh, sure. This one
This one I could see being like mad about. I don't think you
I don't think you ban from Twitch for this. Wait, what are you
talking about? I'm talking about this clip that's put together.
Right? We're not No one is stupid enough to think that Techtone
went through and got all these clips and screenshots. Someone
compiled this library for him. Dan would not make this
Dan hires people who will accept slave wage. Stardust is one
of the people who has accepted slave wage to do work for Wait,
isn't Stardust like little boxes in her head right now, too?
Am I crazy? Stardust does it for free for Dan anyway. What did
you say? Pretty sure Stardust does it for free. Stop it. I tried
to at least Slave wage is at least better than Dan definitely
said she's done stuff for free before. 100%. Why would you do
stuff for Dan if he's out here telling people, "Yeah, she works
for me for free."? Shh. Um Disrespecting the [__]
out of you. Complete utter lack of self-respect. Cherry, have
you ever heard of this like story about
how you build things out of build like men out of clay to do
their bidding for them? They're like put together
No. like a being out of clay. It's called like a golem. And they
they like send them to work for them. Jaysock has explained that
somebody looks like a golem. I forget who. Hasan? Jon Vennerman.
Also Techtone. Oh, Jon Vennerman. Stardust does it like clay
golem. That's true. No, I didn't say that. Golem's are like giants
though. Stardust is uh Well No, she's small. I don't think I've
ever told you guys this, but Stardust was very nice to me when
I got banned. And she was actually more helpful than basically
anybody else. She like tried to help in some way. So, I try not
to talk [__] about Stardust, okay? This is the most
disgusting thing about you. Oh, this person said something nice
to me this one time when I was down bad. I just don't want TO
CALL I DON'T WANT TO TALK [__] ABOUT STARDUST.
I don't talk [__] about Stardust opinion, okay?
no, no, It's like so easy to be nice to me when I'm a victim.
Someone get me the J Q on main clip. I'll make fun of that [__]
all day, okay? I'm just not going to make fun of her appearance,
okay? That's where I will draw the line. Oh, yeah. Yeah, I'm
not making fun of I've met her in person. She's like shorter
than me in person. I wouldn't call her a huge or anything. Oh,
here's the the official moment. I guarantee you a lot of people
will be sewing about how cool this is. Good evening. I've been
thinking deeply about everything going on, specifically against
about the accusation that I'm a misogynist for suing three women.
You're all correct. It's not being fair. That's why I decided
to add Shawn the Black to the lawsuits for gender equality. Shawn,
be sure to thank all of your stalker friends for their constructive
advice.
Uh I'm going to double down. I'm going to say this is misogyny
and he is doing what racist people do and deciding that
never mind. [__] I actually I make make this more
racist if I keep keep talking. Why not include Shawn before?
Uh I don't know. It'd be interesting to look at some of Shawn's
reactions and or the actual complaint against Shawn. I haven't
even I really have not taken the time to look through the other
complaints either. I've not looked at the Frogan complaint. I've
not looked at the Casey complaint. So, uh Queenie, I'd heard
you'd looked at the Frogan reaction.
Had you not and seen that the Frogan reaction was actually probably
more substantive than they're letting on? Like while there is
a chair component that she actually does comment on it a lot
of the time. Well, I haven't looked over the whole video, but
my understanding was she was doing like challenges and [__]
during it. Oh, like is it a transformer episode? Might not be
so Yeah, she was doing like some live event stream. Yeah, she
was like doing like bits and games or whatever the [__]
I thought. That's why I answered I haven't actually watched the
the stream, so I don't have a full answer. Okay. Okay, I'm going
to finish the thought and it's just there are a lot of black
men in Hollywood who have communicated uh similar thing, which
is the idea that the people who control Hollywood and control
their careers, they take black men, they are racist against black
men, and they take black men and they put them in emasculating
situations
to degrade them and put them saying Shawn the Black sold his
patty. That's what you're saying. Shawn the Black sold his patty.
I don't know what this what the what you're saying after Shawn
the Black. his patty to Dan Clancy for I don't have a reference
so I literally don't know the reference you're doing. So sold
his patty. Sold his patty? Is this so Is this one of your sayings?
I don't know this. It is one of his sayings. If he has a saying
it's by definition. No, but seriously seriously if you look it
up I something about I think Martin Lawrence is one of the first
people who's like skits are talking about it. Maybe before him.
Martin Lawrence, Dave Chappelle I think has talked about it.
Um
like the phenomenon of how many black men have been put in movie
roles where they have to wear
and stuff like that. It's just this idea about it, okay? The
humiliation ritual? Let's go. When C go ahead and go show it
when he had to go full hog in that modeling [__]
okay? And then wear the dress, wear that weird like lingerie
thing. C go ahead and go through the humiliation ritual. He didn't
even get anything out of it. He's not even a model anymore. So,
for that entire list, the fact that Ethan just wants to do something
to make it seem like he's not a misogynist, right? I'm not just
picking easy targets. I'm not just picking people that I devalue
based on like any characteristics.
Um the fact that like the next thing that next person he picks
is a black man instead of anything else or anyone else. Uh it's
very interesting.
Mm. Yeah, Kat Williams also.
Also like somebody who has brought it up. I wonder if I should
watch that club uh that Club Shay Shay interview with Kat Williams.
I wonder if that'd be a good one to watch. I know it's like the
big one. you to fight party and you just got to tell him no.
You just got to tell him no. It's fire? It's really good? Well,
yeah, maybe. Maybe that That might be something we do. We'll
see. We'll see. Hold on. From Stardust's video on Frogan, we'll
keep watching. See what else is here. What did you do wrong?
Uh Hezbollah is a is a paramilitary organization
that is also a uh part of the Lebanese parliament. Do we like
them or no? I think it's a resistance group. They're pretty successful
against Israel. Um Oh. But everybody hates them. Like everybody
in the region A lot of people don't like them. Like I like what
you like. I don't have a issue with them. Let's just say. But
they are a terrorist organization. Like they're designated They're
they are designated by the American state as a terrorist organization.
I do not like them then. They're they're terrorist a what? I
I can defend that statement now. It's kind of poorly done.
No, Hasan is so based for that. Here is this brain dead uh clout
driven that I'm friends with cuz I'll be friends with cuz like
Hasan's not ableist. He'll be friends with idiots. Here is this
Or black people. Stop it. Here's this I'm saying stuff. He has
no idea what I'm saying. He's like, "Well, I like it cuz you
do." I'm I'm going to elaborate further and show him why he's
an idiot. Yeah, they're terrorists. They're labeled a terrorist
organization.
Like I'm sorry, but that you're just like real for that. Shawn
had to teach him about critical thinking, okay? Don't just agree
with what I say. They are terrorist organization. You shouldn't
just agree with me. God, what a kind and and like considerate
mentor Hasan is. He just He had to He had to just nudge him like,
"Don't just listen to me." Wow.
I didn't think about that, Cherry. That is really I you know,
I new found respect for Hasan. Let's go. Was this Hasan Orbiter?
It probably was. Yeah, it definitely was. This is what we just
watched this clip.
deserved 9/11. I can't dis Yeah, that's the one. Yeah, hold on.
More clips. More clips. watched that clip. Oh, it's a Destiny
clip for some reason. This is a 17-year-old whose family was
murdered in front of her and she was kidnapped for 50 days and
continually while being in captivity. Nothing to say? You're
not going to acknowledge what just happened?
I will acknowledge what just happened.
This woman who you claimed was continually
in captivity did not claim to have been
Hold on. This is This is very small. We need bigger. They suffered
At least one person with me said they suffered physical abuse.
In that interview, she says that at least half the hostages she
spoke to said they were assaulted. At no point did she claim
that anything had happened to her. And to my knowledge so far,
no hostages have given first hand accounts of being assaulted
in captivity.
I remember thinking I made Now is the moment. Something what
you thought about is going to happen. And then I remember I turned
around. He was standing with his gun and the gun was pointing
out at And he was huffing and breathing heavily and he had a
face like a monster, like a beast. Like this.
So I stood up and held a blanket, a small blanket to cover myself
and he came towards me and just pointed a gun really hard at
my forehead screaming at me, "Take it off. Take it off." and
punching me until I could not hold the the
the towel anymore. And he started touching me and I resisted.
And then he dragged me to the bedroom. And then he he forced
me to commit a act on him. No hostages have given first-hand
accounts of being assaulted in captivity. Okay, how can this
be in the same video? It's almost like she didn't watch it at
all. Okay. Well. Wow. I mean that looks bad. I'm literally not
The only I I don't know. I don't I don't know if this is true.
My only thing would be is that 100% a hostage testimony or is
that or is that the woman who used to work at Tower 7? I'm not
sure. Wait, say that again.
Was there Was there any first-hands from October 7th? Cuz it
could be that she's making the Oh, that like she wasn't she wasn't
held hostage and this wasn't happened this didn't happen in captivity.
That happened like after the That happened like Yeah, I'm I'm
not sure though. I I literally don't know what a woman's claiming
or like I haven't watched the documentary, so. Yeah, you'd have
to listen to more of them. Cuz she does say in captivity as in
once they took them into uh or whatever, so. Like what is going
on? Why are there This is like two now where it could have just
been the clips, but it's like included
Destiny, but he has like no real commentary that's necessary
for the clip. Oh, I mean to begin with for one Why couldn't he
get the Reddit post or the clip from the Reddit post? noticed
I've absolutely noticed that for a bunch of these I think this
was a thing that I pointed out. I pointed this out to Queenman.
I don't really talk about it on stream cuz it seems kind of ghetto,
but I do believe people were farming um these clips from LSF
just like running the clips through Dest like basically like
trying to farm them from Destiny even when he wouldn't comment
just so they could get like Destiny streamed further pushed up
on the board. Like farming the Ethan Hassan Destiny stuff. The
the Ethan versus Hassan stuff. Farming like Anti-Denim's clips,
Anti-Whoever's clips, right? Yeah, that's basically
I was saying Portobello's got it. Clips and stuff for just pushing
uh a bunch of content out of his that if people like names search
him it's going to be just a whole bunch of irrelevant clips and
videos and stuff like that and Reddit post and like anything
that might be like controversial, let's say, it would be like
harder to instantly pop up. Manic Ink says Destiny is already
pushed up as far as it can go. Also true, unrelated, but also
true. So. Ugh. Go ahead and watch the next clip.
Uh But like those that makes sense. It just doesn't make sense
in this folder. Yeah, sure. Sure. Sure.
Why does Sherry have the M next to her name? I'm actually not
sure. Oh, I did that to go after Kelly. I'll fix my nickname.
One sec. Oh, I see. Seeing my brothers before the war and after
the war, they became different
Uh my my dad also has PTSD and it's very awful to see and seeing
him have to understand like what is okay and what's not okay
to do and you know, society just says, "Oh, well you're not at
war." This clip like actually gets so much better now. God damn.
get over it. And He's got PTSD from these [__] congressional
trials, okay? And I'm telling him this is not okay and he's like,
"THIS IS HOW I GREW UP. THIS IS WHAT I KNOW." AND UH they come
over and they they they have to relearn that they're safe now.
They have to relearn that they're safe. What What did he mean
your dad had to relearn what was okay and what was not
IS YOU DON'T GET TO feel safe. Every second you have to take
as a blessing because at any time a mortar can drop next to you,
near you. Your friends are dead. My dad was in the bathroom stall,
okay? He was in the bathroom with one of his best friends brushing
his teeth. One second he's brushing his teeth. The next second
he doesn't know where he He can't hear. He can't see. It's actually
so [__] disgusting that Denims would laugh and or
mock Tectone's storytelling ability, okay? And his friend is
gone. As well as the majority of the flesh on his legs, as well
as the entirety of his ear. Gone. Have you seen my dad? He's
pretty much half robot at this point in case you guys don't know.
He's pretty much half robot because a mortar
hit the bathroom where he was brushing his teeth and killed one
of his best friends. Okay. some fat [__] go live
on the internet and say,
"I HOPE THEY GET PTSD."
What a horrible [__] thing to say. And now it would
be great if she ever does show true remorse
and say, "I apologize. That was a moment of ignorance." She literally
apologized.
"Stupid for me to say." Ugh. Would be great, but instead all
I've seen is her doubling down. She did apologize. What What
a joke. Dude, these people are such [__] liars, dude.
These people are such disingenuous liars. [__] joke.
I think Frogan eventually kind of sort of halfway apologized
while justifying like way later. Uh I think it was like the third
I think she doubled down twice on the PTSD comments and then
she kind of apologized. remember the apology. I'm sure it was
like a half-assed apology.
I don't think anybody owes you a full-throated apology. At most
they just need like a quarter of their throat, but okay. Who
gives a [__] about Frogan anyways? She talks [__]
about vets. That's awesome. The military and vets, that's funny.
Uh protected class bro. troops to Yeah, I guess TOS violation,
but like holy
Who cares? Cuz I seriously
Whatever happened to people actually being the victim of the
thing that they cry about. Remind me, did Tectone go into the
military or it's literally just the fact that like he had family
members in the
Um his So Tectone is a victim of these same things because his
dad's PTSD from the military is probably what led to one, the
things that Tectone is epigenetically tied to, and two, the care.
the attempted murder or whatever when when Tectone's dad is That's
the PTSD, right? When Tectone's dad holds him down and says,
"Tell me why you should why I shouldn't kill you right now."
That's probably like military PTSD. So Tectone's kind of a victim,
right? No, I can't know what came first.
American troops. I do not know. I do not know what came first,
the chicken or the egg in this situation. There are some people
who just want to So they join the military cuz they think this
is going to be the place where they can like legally kill. There
are some people who feel like they want to protect and want to
serve their country. And they go into the military and end up
having to kill somebody.
So yeah, no.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Why a rope? You're
Are you talking about Tectone right now? He tried to be a WWE
wrestler and
Also did steroids and lost his hair in the process. There's no
way you're talking about Tectone right now. Oh. Dude, the MTF
allegations become more and more believable. Like he did testosterone
so he lost his hairline? Okay. All right. Interesting.
pathetic That is actually pathetic. I used to say he's going
to sit here and cry like rivers
uh about like veterans. FTM. Whoops. Sorry. You go ahead. Cry
about veterans and the And the thing that he wanted to do was
roleplay fighting other men. Yeah, I mean I think he just wanted
to get his head in a lot of crotches to be honest with you, but
I'll hit play. disgusting Mommy, don't Who's shielding from the
bomb vest? Well, we both have them strapped to our chest cuz
we're both Arabs, so I think neither of us neither of us, I guess.
In a scenario like that, who would die first, me or you? I don't
know. Or or would they die at the same time? Mine wouldn't go
off. I I just I know it wouldn't go off. you would die by proximity?
part of me would probably skimp out on like the part of me would
skimp out on the actual supplies for the bomb vest, so I think
mine wouldn't work as well.
So I think I'm That's insane. And yours would go off what I don't
understand? Like I feel like whenever people are like like being
being hated on as
they're never original. Like I I want like original [__]
Okay, you call me you call me Hijab the Hutt. Tectone's
Why do I feel like I have not heard that before, but I should
have? Hijab the
Why That's like the most obvious thing. I just I I feel like
I've not heard it. What the He's an ugly [__] freak
that got
liking loli. I know it must have been said in my chat at some
point.
All right. I'm going to be offended by an ugly bald
that's divorced and likes loli. Right. Okay. Ooh.
Can't sleep at night because of that.
A a known predator.
Dates girls that are closer in age to his daughter than him.
Oh my god, can't sleep at night. The the great thing is I don't
know why she's taking shots at Keemstar, but that's funny. past
a school with no thoughts he was tweeting about her a lot, too.
uh after the stream. vet stuff him off, too, didn't it? True.
Yeah. past a school with no thoughts and Keemstar has to [__]
control himself. And then Ethan Klein, I have no words. I have
no words for Ethan Klein.
Uh that's anti-Semitic. His existence just speaks. Yeah, that's
absolutely I can sense it. I can tell Ethan Klein is evil by
virtue of his genetics, of his birth, okay? It's obvious what
Frogan's saying here.
I I have nothing to can him. You know he portioned me yesterday?
What? Hila portioned me yesterday. Hila looks like she I I That's
insane. Stop. I'm not I'm not going to go. I'm not going to do
that. I'm not going to attack the poor I I just I'm not going
to do that. I'm not going to attack the disabled. I I just won't
do it. Wow. Have you ever seen the Red Bar bit? I certainly have
seen the Red Bar bit. needs to see the Red Bar bit. Jared needs
to see the Red Bar Jared, do you know the Red Bar bit with Hila
Klein? Did you watch this with us? Was she No, wait. Red Bar
obsessively hates her. Is it the aerobics thing? Yeah, okay.
I thought you might have seen it with us. Yeah. No, pull it up.
I don't remember. Red Bar Radio Hila compilation. ever think
to start maybe Dude, the the funniest one was when that that
lefty gay old fumador account on on Twitter posted a compilation
of Red Bar clips mainly from the Hila. And the the very end of
those 3-minute compilation of Red Bar clips, it's just the one
where he says he's like zooming on Ethan Hila's faces. He's going,
"Listen, you know, if you saw a a thousand of those come over
the hell, you know, you might you might retreat and come up with
a plan for Germany." You know, I'm not saying it makes it right,
but
That's not funny. It's just the last clip, but it's just so crazy.